或者说有一天你怀着孕，
大着肚子，
两口子感情不好了，
你回到娘家有地儿住，
回到娘家有钱花，
娘家给你托底的人的话，
反而她可以选择性的可要可不要，
越是像你这种没有娘家人托底的，
没有人给你撑腰的，
没有人给你保障的，
你月是该要彩礼，
我家里的情况条件是比较差，
我结婚了，
我父母大概率是不会给我嫁妆的，
那这种情况下，
我想的是可能男方那边彩礼我最多象征性的要那么一点点一两万，
这种你得先跟我说一说，
咱自己是什么条件啊，
什么学历，
工作怎么样，
男方是什么条件，
咱要彩礼这个事儿，
并不是说我必须得有嫁妆，
我才有资格要彩礼，
因为我理解的彩礼是给女性怀孕生产哺乳的一种，
相当于担保金、
保证金一样的东西，
他不是说我非得要配嫁妆，
我才能要彩礼，
我认为不是这样的逻辑。
但先说一下自己是啥条件，
我是本科班，
也是一个班本而已，
我现在的工作是在事业单位，
我对象他是硕士，
他是公务员，
我的家庭情况就比较差，
我对象的家庭情况也没有说很好，
就是普通，
他父母是做什么的呢？
他父母开个便利店，
他妈妈打点零工，
这种他是独生子吗？
他不是，
他有一个姐姐，
我也有一个妹妹，
还有一个弟弟，
那关于财礼这个事儿，
你跟男方已经沟通过了吗？
没有，
因为说实话，
我的家庭情况我觉得不是很好，
我在这方面我一直不知道该怎么去沟通，
因为我家里自己条件比较差的话，
我跟我家里关系也没有很好，
我也不知道该跟谁去沟通，
去聊这些，
那你找我就对了。
姑娘啊，
越是像你的这种情况，
原生家庭给不了托举，
越是该要彩礼，
反而是那种说原生家庭特别好，
原生家庭可以给你买房买车，
原生家庭可以给你，
如果说有一天你怀着孕，
大着肚子，
两口子感情不好了，
你回到娘家有地儿住，
回到娘家有钱花，
娘家给你托底的人的话，
反而她可以选择性的可要可不要，
越是像你这种没有娘家人托底的，
没有人给你撑腰的，
没有人给你保障的，
你越是该要彩礼，
而且一定是在婚前就要，
到婚前就要，
要到手才对。
我自己现在存款是有20万，
是我自己攒了，
照自己的这些财产和彩礼你可以分开存，
绝个例子，
你的这20万假设存在建行，
那你就存一个夫妻，
存一个定期存到建行，
如果彩礼给你了，
咱就存到农行，
咱也可以存一个定期吃利息那种，
结了婚了之后，
这张建行卡，
这张农行卡不要绑定你的支付宝，
不要绑定你的微信，
也不要绑定你的工资。
卡，
你的工资卡另外拿一张，
比如说中行好，
这三张卡是敬畏分明的，
只要说你这20万是你婚前的存款，
你存个定期，
结婚之后你没有再往里面存钱，
那么这20万就算将来你跟他要离的话，
也不用拿出来分这个彩礼钱，
比如说8万或者10万，
你存到了农行，
这个也是你的婚前个人财产，
如果有一天你俩要分开的话，
得以看一下，
第一你俩结婚时间长不长，
第二有没有孕育孩子，
就这8万、
十万的彩礼的话，
她是有可能涉及到退的，
但通常情况下，
如果怀孕了，
生孩子了，
或者结婚时间两三年了，
那也是变成你的婚前个人财产，
就不用退了。
我为什么说越是像你这样的女孩子，
第一原生家庭靠不住，
第二，
自己的工作能力又不是特别强，
赚钱能力又不是特别强，
越像你这样的女孩子越是应该要彩礼，
好的原因我跟你讲清楚啊，
所有结婚的女孩子都面临着共同的一个数据，
所有对婚姻有向往的，
现在浓情蜜意的，
你们都要清醒的看到一个数据，
大数据摆在这里，
小一半概率是要离婚的，
理解了吧，
那你知道是什么时候分开呢？
有可能是你怀孕8个月的时候，
有可能是你临产的时候，
有可能是你哺乳期的时候，
都有可能，
那我这八万十万的最起码能保证我能活下去，
我的孩子也能活下去，
最起码能保证这个好的，
那我想问一下我的这种个人。
财产就一定不能在婚后投入生活，
其实我还挺希望能够生活条件能好一点，
他其实也没有很有钱，
我在想有没有办法保住自己个人财产的情况下，
用于婚内的支出是完全没可能吗？
姑娘你听我一句劝好不好好的，
真正的婚姻是从生完孩子养孩子才开始的，
如果你怀孕、
生产、
哺乳这个过程当中，
包括孩子都到2岁了，
在这个过程当中，
你真的觉得男方很有责任心，
很善良，
对你很好，
这孩子也很好，
你们真的感情很稳定，
钱想怎么用怎么用，
婚前的钱想怎么用怎么用，
但是在你怀孕、
生产、
母乳之前的话，
我建议你还是装熊，
你就没有存款啊，
我建议你还是小气一点啊，
好的，
那我想问一下，
假如不要小孩呢？
因为男方他也有这种想法，
只是说我们两个都没有很明确，
因为未来的事情说不好，
万一有变化，
我想是两种情况都咨询一下，
我给你讲，
讲白了啊，
如果男方现在声称不要小孩，
男方声称他要定，
我有一个非常容易激发众目的观点，
那就男方去结扎，
为什么？
你看看香港那些导演吧，
你看看那个声称丁克的，
丁到50岁了，
偷偷在外面生孩子的人吧，
因为人他发展到一定阶段了之后。
比如说他爸妈死了，
他在这个社会上，
在这个世界没有什么亲缘关系了，
他就会生出一种想生孩子的冲动，
而你就生不了了，
你别说50了，
你到40你想生孩子都够呛够呛的啦，
是不要稀里糊涂的啊，
所以哪怕现在说不要小孩，
也不能说要不要彩礼啊，
这些是可以对，
是的，
好的，
我还有最后一个问题想咨询一下，
但不是和婚姻有关的，
你是我的爸爸，
他因为犯事儿进去了，
现在出来了，
但其实我跟我爸爸的感情很淡，
但是他突来了以后，
可能他有想法的改变吧，
又开始怀念心情了，
但我不想跟他有联系的原因是因为我觉得他这个人没有变化，
他还是跟以前一样混蛋，
他当年为什么进去的呀？
对呀，
不是不是，
那是什么，
这个一定要说吗？
一定要说呀，
通过他为什么进去来判断你将来要不要跟他联系啊，
我他是开始的是吗？
不是他就是我不用联系了，
能躲多远躲多远，
那他这种情况的话，
我不理他，
那也完全不给他联系方式，
那他以后假如说要找到我支付赡养费的话，
他会闹到我单位嘛，
就他会有渠道知道我的工作地点这种的有可能啊，
因为你有同学，
你有老师，
你有朋友，
你有其他的亲人，
知道你的工作单位在哪里是有可能的，
但是听好了姐妹们啊，
去闹也没有关系。
我承认我的父亲就是这么不堪，
我承认我的亲就是一个赌鬼，
那我想要跟他断绝关系这件事情能不能得到舆论的支持呢？
你看看蔡少芬啊，
蔡少芬专门发了一个记者招待会，
就要跟他妈断绝关系，
舆论一片支持，
早就该断了，
为什么不早断哦，
也就是说他就算找到你的单位了，
你不要怕丢脸，
你不要怕告诉别人实情。
再有一个，
你说要赡养这个问题的话，
那就法院判喽，
你去法院告我了，
法院判每个月该给800，
我800块钱打你卡里就完事儿了。
好的，
我不是不认识呀，
我单纯的不想联系，
不想任何的沟通，
那这样子我了解了，
我跟他完全断绝关系，
没必要去顾及到以后那些事情，
越是这样，
姑娘你自己啊，
在内心深处的话，
一旦当你自己不把我的父亲曾经做过了我的父亲是个赌鬼这件事情，
你不再把这个事情当成一种弱点的时候，
就没有人可以攻击你，
好的，
我了解了，
好，
谢谢，
就这样啊，
有多少姐妹爸妈不靠谱的，
要么是爸爸是个赌鬼，
要么是妈妈是个赌鬼，
妈妈是个骗子，
爸爸是个人渣，
妈妈是一个不负责任的，
或者说甚至于出现过那种什么爸爸是个奸犯，
奸犯或者怎么样，
有没有这样的，
有这样的人啊，
记住了，
当有一天你不再把这件事情当成是一个弱点的时候，
就没有人可以再攻击你，
虽然你有他的DNA，
但是你这一辈子把。
自己修炼成一个正直的、
善良的、
有责任心的人，
你就成功了，
你对抗了基因，
多牛逼的一件事，
记得点赞关注哦。